en el último vídeo aprendimos un poco
acerca de lo que es un valor esperado de
una variable aleatoria y vimos que en
realidad es simplemente la media de la
población o es lo mismo pero una
variable aleatoriedad donde la población
sea infinita no puede tomar todos los
términos para el promedio de esto y lo
que tienes que decir es que hay algunos
de estos términos ocurren con alguna
frecuencia o con alguna probabilidad por
lo que pueden tomar la suma de las
probabilidades ponderadas y lo que vimos
en el último vídeo fue exactamente lo
mismo fuimos sumando todo y dividiendo
entre algún número de probabilidad
excepto que este método trabaja con una
población infinita que es lo que a una
variable aleatoria se refiere y después
de hecho pues sólo seguir realizando el
experimento que genera tu variable
aleatoria y más adelante calcular el
valor esperado que esta particular
distribución binomial da y que hemos
estado estudiando con nuestro ejemplo de
lanzamiento de la moneda
y en este vídeo vamos a encontrar una
forma general para la esperanza
así que decimos que la variable
aleatoria x es igual al número de éxitos
el número de éxitos con la probabilidad
p después de en intentos con la
probabilidad probabilidad
que puede ser cualquier probabilidad
después de n intentos y empecé un poco
en forma general aquí pero lo que quiero
decir es el número de caras como nuestro
éxito de probabilidad punto 5 que
obtengo después de m lanzamientos y es
lo mismo solo que empecé de una forma
más general por aquí para que tengas una
idea más clara ahora podemos figurarnos
cuál es el valor esperado de esta
variable y vimos de hecho que con alguna
cierta probabilidad esta variable al
actor ya se torna en una bonita
distribución binomial que se forma como
un tipo de campana o una curva de
campana que vamos a estudiar un poco más
adelante de este tipo de curvas pero por
el momento les mostraré esto y ya les di
aquí la respuesta que el valor esperado
es n por p y ahora vamos a verlo de una
forma muy intuitiva el valor esperado de
esta variable aleatoria es n veces
pero déjame hacerlo de una forma más
tangible para ti por lo que si decimos
que x es igual con este diferente color
al número de anotaciones en la sexta
hablando de baloncesto que hago después
de n tiros después de n tiros donde
tengo como la probabilidad de hacer una
anotación va a ser igual al 40% y
sabemos que el valor esperado de
anotaciones después de 10 tiros es lo
que nos interesa así que sabemos que el
número de ciertas anotaciones que
estamos esperando es algo que nos va a
resultar después de 10 tiros donde 10
tiros es el 40% entonces lo que tengo
que hacer es multiplicar la probabilidad
por el número de anotaciones que estoy
tomando así que al hacer la
multiplicación de la probabilidad por el
número de anotaciones nos va a dar un
valor igual a 4
y sé que dije que era necesario que
vieras de forma estricta el valor
esperado como el número de tiros que
estás esperando hacer porque algunas
veces las distribuciones de probabilidad
podrían ser un poco más extrañas y sería
una forma diferente de una distribución
binomial lo puedes ver de esta forma que
el número de tiros esperados por hacer
es el valor esperado o puedes verlo como
mejor te convenga para que tengas un
buen resultado pues si tienes el 40 por
ciento de tiros bueno si tomas al
respecto 10 tiros entonces el resultado
es que probablemente hagas cuatro
anotaciones y quizás sientas que puedes
no sé hacer seis tiros buenos o tres o
algún otro resultado pero la forma más
probable es que hagas cuatro anotaciones
en mi cabeza la forma en como pienso
esto es tratar lo de hacer intuitivo por
lo que cada vez que tiras tienes el 40%
de probabilidad de que la tiene cierto
por lo que podrías decir que siempre
haces el 40% de las anotaciones y me
gusta pensarlo de esta forma porque
siento que es un tanto intuitivo
pero ahora probemos no sólo a nosotros
mismos que esto es de verdad cierto para
cualquier variable aleatoria que
describe una distribución binomial
entonces para una distribución binomial
cuál es la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a k y entonces digamos que si son
n tiros vamos a escoger cada de estos y
hemos hecho esto en dos vídeos
anteriores para que si quieres regresar
de checarlo estará perfecto entonces lo
multiplicamos las combinaciones de nk
por la probabilidad de cualquiera de
estas ocurrencias particulares así que
si estoy anotando katíos va a ser la
probabilidad de que haga cualquier tiro
los cuales la p va a ser elevada a la
cara pues hay la probabilidad de que
sean cada anotaciones y luego estos
tiros los vamos a multiplicar por la
probabilidad de fallo que sería 1 - p a
la n menos k que es los n tiros menos
los k posibles anotaciones por lo que en
cualquier distribución binomial esta es
la probabilidad de que obtengas éxito
cierto ahora sabemos que el valor
esperado
la forma en cómo calculamos el valor
esperado de las variables aleatorias es
tomar la probabilidad de suma ponderada
y no quiero confundirte mucho y si tú
quizás este vídeo se te hace confuso
puedes detenerlo y repasarlo para que te
sientas un poco más cómodo ahora vamos a
obtenerlo un poco técnico pero espero te
sea más cómodo si ponemos sig más para
la anotación de la suma para que estés
más cómodo con los coeficientes de la
distribución y cosas como esa y
regresando un poco el valor esperado es
una probabilidad de su más ponderadas
así que lo que nos interesa hacer es
tomar la probabilidad de cuando x es
igual a k
entonces vamos a tener que va a ir acá
desde cero hasta n pues podemos tener
cero anotaciones hasta entonces vamos a
tener que el valor esperado de la
variable aleatoria se escribe como la
suma y vamos a tener que escalar
por la probabilidad de que x sea igual
acá y bien la probabilidad de tener k
tiros es la de aquí arriba no serían las
combinaciones de enka por p a la k por 1
- p a la n menos k ahora bien si k es
igual a 0 qué pasa con este primer
término tenemos que sería 0 por todo lo
demás entonces en realidad todo este
término se nos hace 0 pues sería 0 por
las combinaciones tienen cero por placer
o por 1 - p a la n menos será entonces
en realidad podemos reescribirlo de la
siguiente forma vamos a tener que 0 x en
0 por placer o por la probabilidad de
fallo de uno que es 1 - p a la enee
menos 0 luego cuando acá es igual a 1
es1 las combinaciones de enero en 1 p a
la 1 por 1 - p a la enee menos 1 y así
sucesivamente hasta llegar a n cuando
acá es igual a n
por las combinaciones de nn p a la n por
una menos p d n a la n
cd así que este término de aquí en
realidad no nos va a importar lo vamos a
ignorar puesto que no nos afecta para
nada en nuestra suma y en realidad
podemos empezar a partir de cuando acá
es igual a 1 que sería a partir de todos
estos términos que acabo de encerrar y
entonces si hacemos esto prácticamente
reescribimos lo de aquí el valor
esperado de nuestra variable la actoría
es igual a la suma pero ahora con acá a
partir de uno hasta n de acá por las
combinaciones de nkp a la k por 1 - p a
la n - acá y veamos qué podemos hacer
con todo esto entonces todo lo que
hicimos atrás fue para deshacernos del
primer término puesto que es un tipo de
truco que realizamos para poder
simplificar esto eventualmente para el
resultado que queríamos obtener así que
ubs perdón esto es de mi ipod que
quieren ser sincronizados no le hagamos
caso
y entonces en donde íbamos bien ya
recordé entonces la suma que es a partir
de acá igual a uno hasta n
y luego cada por las combinaciones de
enka es lo mismo que tener kn
factoriales sobre cada factor ya por n
k factorial en el denominador al ser la
combinatoria por p a la k por 1 - p a la
n menos acá y aquí podemos hacer un poco
de simplificación pues tenemos que es
cada dividió entre cada factoría de
cierto entonces tal vez si les
escribimos de forma diferente en nuestro
caso actor ya sabemos que acá
factoriales cada por cada menos uno por
cada menos dos y así hasta llegar hasta
1 cada porque a menos 1 sucesivamente
que es lo mismo que tener acá por cada
menos 1 factoría del puesto los números
que siguen después de cada menos 1 son
menores que éste entonces podemos poner
que está factorial
así que es aquí abajo acá porque a menos
1 factorial y esto es para poderlos
cancelar cancelamos esto y ahora supongo
que podríamos seguir simplificando lo
esto va a ser igual a la suma desde acá
igual a uno hasta n de benefactor ya
sobre cada menos 1 factorial por n menos
acá factorial por la probabilidad de
anotar que esperar acá por la de fallo
que es 1 - p a la n menos acá y ahora lo
que quiero hacer y recordando en nuestra
mente lo que teníamos que el valor
esperado es igual a n - n por perdón
como podemos llegar a ese resultado si
tenemos todo esto así que vamos a
factorizar a n por p en esta parte de
aquí
tenemos que en el factorial puede ser
escrito como n por n 1 factorial y
entonces los podemos sacar de nuestra
suma pues pearl acá es lo mismo que
tener p
por p a la que menos uno y entonces los
términos ya no dependen de acá y podemos
factorizar los entonces los sacamos de
nuestra suma y nos va a quedar que esto
va a ser igual a n por p por la suma
desde acá igual a uno hasta ndm-1
factorial sobre cada menos uno factorial
por n
factorial n - caf actor ya el factor él
iba afuera perdón por vea la cara menos
uno
por la probabilidad de fallo que sigue
siendo uno menos a la n menos acá y
estamos cerca pues recuerda que
queríamos el resultado del valor
esperado de la variable y es como lo
hicimos antes entonces a que debería de
ser igual esto bueno pues ya tenemos a n
por p ahora sólo resta probar que esto
de aquí va a ser igual a 1 y para poder
hacer eso vamos a simplificar y hacer
unas pequeñas sustituciones así que
déjame hacer la sustitución no sé
digamos que a es igual a que acá menos 1
que ve es igual a n menos 1 y luego a
que debería de ser igual n menos acá
bien n menos acá sabemos que es igual a
k menos 1 entonces a más uno es igual
acá y luego ve más uno es igual a n por
lo que en el menos acá sería igual a más
1 - b menos uno donde esto de aquí se va
a cancelar y entonces nos queda que es
igual
a menos
lo siguiente sería entonces que tenemos
que es en el porte por la suma si acá
empieza desde 1 entonces igual a cero
puesto que es igual acá menos 11 menos 1
es 0 y luego tenemos que va a ir hasta
cuando acá es igual a n ya que va a ser
igual entonces acá si esto es igual a n
si acá es igual adn entonces a sería
igual a n -1 cierto entonces teníamos
que esta suma iría hasta n menos uno que
es lo mismo que b por lo que podemos
reescribir la suma aquí entonces esto
siempre va a ser un poco confuso quizás
te gustaría pausar el vídeo y volverlo a
pensar pero bueno aquí ya lo hicimos y
ya no tenemos mucho tiempo entonces voy
a seguir adelante ahora n 1 factorial
sería igualdad b factorial sobre a
factorial y n menos acá
sería n - k factorial si ya lo siguiente
ya habíamos hecho por aquí a que era
igual n menos acá pero lo voy a volver a
repetir para no confundirnos porque no
me queda claro aquí que es lo que hice
entonces si queremos que sea n menos acá
factorial sería n que se ve más uno
menos acá que sería a más uno entonces
se cancelan estos y nos queda que esto
es igual a b menos a factorial por la
probabilidad
de éxito que esté a la cara menos uno
que es a por uno menos p al ave menos a
qué es lo que dijimos anteriormente y lo
hemos hecho muy bien hasta ahora pero
ahora la pregunta sería qué es esto que
tenemos por aquí y esto sea la
probabilidad de bueno déjame lorre
escribo de una forma simple entonces
esto es igual a n por p por la suma
desde a igual a 0 hasta b y estas son
las combinaciones deben a que nos quiere
decir que tengo b cosas de las cuales
escogemos a de ahí y cuántas diferentes
formas podría haber de esto entonces lo
multiplicamos por p ara por 1 - p al ave
menos a y entonces todo esto de aquí que
nos quiere decir esto es que estás
tomando cada término de la distribución
binomial entonces cuál es la
probabilidad para cuando a es igual a
cero
esta es la probabilidad para lo
siguiente vamos a hacer un pequeño
dibujo rápidamente para darnos una idea
de lo que la distribución está haciendo
entonces para cuando a iguales a cero
tendrías esta probabilidad lo para
cuando a es igual a 1 tendríamos para
cuando es igual a 1 tendríamos esta otra
probabilidad y así sucesivamente
entonces si te das cuenta es como una
especie de curva de campana o algo así
entonces este término de aquí es para
cada una de estas probabilidades o cada
uno de estos valores pero pues estamos
sumando estamos sumando todas estas
probabilidades y entonces estamos
sumando sobre todos los valores que la
variable aleatoria puede tomar por lo
que si sumamos todas estas
probabilidades dicha suma nos tiene que
dar 1 cierto pues esto es como decir que
son las probabilidades de las caras de
que nos dan el éxito como lo hicimos en
el de los lanzamientos y si sumamos las
probabilidades nos tenía que
el resultado 1 para que sea probabilidad
entonces esta suma de aquí es nuestra
probabilidad de la distribución por lo
que va a ser igual a 1 es la
probabilidad completa que es 1 y
entonces así llegamos a que el valor
esperado de nuestra variable aleatoria
de x es igual a n por p donde es el
número de veces del experimento n&p es
la probabilidad de éxito de dicho
experimento y este caso es sólo para
distribución binomial no para cualquier
variable aleatoria solo para la binomial
de cualquier forma se me acabó el tiempo
nos vemos